[Music]
almost most people are back and hope
that the sound of the discussion will
bring the rest couldn't give me more
pleasure to do this to introduce Herman
Feshbach than anything else
Herman's been my teacher let's say since
1950 and my collaborators since 1960 as
I was saying earlier he and Vicki were
the reason that we started this Center
for Theoretical Physics and the
inspiration for it and he was the first
director of it we all know who he is so
I'm not going to say anymore Herman
are we on yep
thank you author I can't I can't resist
but make the following remark at the end
of the talks this month this afternoon
as you all know economists have proven
that it's difficult to predict the
future and we also now know that
historians and feel theorists find it
difficult to predict the past when a
mean good ol early days before the war
there was no theoretical nuclear physics
at MIT there were a number of
experimentalist Rob Lee Evans has been
mentioned Van de Graaff Bill Buckner and
Stan Livingston who built the cyclotron
that was mentioned earlier today but
there was the extensible or the well the
nucleus theorists was presumably Phil
Morris but he had given up nuclear
physics he had done a number of papers
with the Fiske Jim Fisk and Leonard
shift but then got interested in
acoustics so for me the arrival of Vice
cup Zacharias no Rossi was an absolutely
great event the greatest event in my
career of course Vicky came with with a
couple postdocs
Wayne Bowers and and Ted Welton and we
got a great deal of excitement and
interest in those days Vicky of course
was at the forefront of the field and so
for the first time as it were I was at
the forefront of the
but beyond that there was Vicky's Vicky
as a role model
I wrote this 20 years ago almost now
when Vicky retired let me just quote it
again his was an unquenchable desire to
understand the essential physical
elements involved in a phenomenon to
strip away the complexities of a
detailed explanation and to make visible
the underlying ideas and concepts it's
not a tude which we at MIT particularly
have come to appreciate and emulate let
me also while I'm still reminiscing we
were told today about the halcyon days
right after World War two where nuclear
physicists were extremely popular and I
have two stories in that regard
one is the Shelter Island story the
Vicky's told you but let me tell you at
the beginning of it Vicky and I and
Julian Schwinger wrote down on the train
from Boston to New York discussing of
course the data from Columbia and we
then went up to then the headquarters of
the American Physical Society or I think
maybe it's the American Institute of
Physics I can't quite recall but anyway
we waited around and then a rickety old
bus arrived we got on it across the
bridge into Queens and from Queens into
Long Island at which point we were met
by a pair of motorcycle policemen and
the bus drove all the way to Greenpoint
between Greenpoint reports at the end of
the island 120 miles is so escorted by
motorcycle police so we were as I should
say very highly he got that green point
we were given a big luscious dinner now
the other story is a few years later
Bernie Feld had put me down as a
possible consultant to a company called
nuclear development associates and the
AEC decided vicki was also they have
decided to do a security studies so one
day I was told to come down it was
actually rather inconvenient but I
course agreed to New York to Columbus
Circle where I was to be where I was to
be asked questions I had difficulty
getting down I had started out good and
early but the dc4 that American Airlines
was flying in those days failed two of
them in a row so I arrived just in time
to come into this meeting now here I am
just see was I associate professor at
the time I think I was but after all
thirty two years old or something
and the room was filled with people I
didn't know of course I was all alone
and the chief of the security system for
the AEC was there Admiral Cochrane had
come up from Washington just for this
purpose
and I was asked you know whether they
would mind if they would make a
transcript of what I said and I had been
warned by Vicki and so I said no I
wouldn't mind if they took it down but
I'd want a copy then the first question
came and it's man asked me you are a
member of the Executive Committee of the
Cambridge Association of scientists that
was a forerunner of the
the FDA yes I said yes I was question do
you have you seen any communist
infiltration in that forty I the
transcript says fresh back laughter and
after a while I found out what was going
on
namely Wendell Furi was on on that boy
and this dangerous communist would be
endangering of course our security but
that gives you I think two sides of our
popularity now what I'm going to do is
narrow my discussion to the discussion
of reactions it's an interesting story
in a way because so though there are
very random influences the result is
quite coherent and so I'd like to make
sure we get those those random things
that did happen now Vicki came in with
of course the reputation of being the
expert on nuclear reactions he had
invented the evaporation model 37 and
then there was a very seminal paper with
dealing I guess 39 and this is used to
this day in that domain in which
evaporation theory is valid we added a
little bit on to it later when we
discussed or added to it the conditions
of conservation of parroting and angular
momentum so after the when he arrived we
got to working once more on reactions
and of course the big thing was
residences and so with Beasley we worked
a paper on the boundary condition model
which had the great merit of being
simple and easy to understand and in
fact at the same time Bigler worked on a
similar model but of course made it much
more elaborate by making it
multi-channel or as we were
single-channel
but the big breakthrough came with
Marshalls data on the total cross
sections for nuclei interacting with MeV
neutrons I'll show you that curves
shortly and I remember sitting with Hans
bethe had a breakfast somewhere some
meeting and we were discussing the data
and we both were puzzled as to how that
could come out of out of all the
resonances we knew that existed in in
that that neutron nucleus interaction
well what developed of course was the
paper with Porter and Vice cup on the
what we call the cloudy crystal ball
model it's now called the optical model
which I really dislike as a term because
it really is referring to things which
are valid at a much higher energy this
is a low-energy story and Dave Saxon of
also worked at that time and there's a
wood Saxon potential which everybody
knows about what we got of course was a
very good
now where is that gadget
a very good match with the data this is
actually a theory this axis is the
energy really there's the total
cross-section and units of the area of
the sphere and here is the radius and
you see that this represents a very
smooth slowly energy dependent except
you know you get a 1 over B law at the
beginning here but once you get beyond
that it's just a threshold effect these
things vary rather slowly with energy
and actually also with radius which is
the same as same with mass number but
that's not the important thing we first
did this with well let me just say
that's not the important thing what the
important thing was is in the appendix
to that paper where vicki showed that
you could get an understanding of these
phenomena by energy averaging the
resonances in other words you could
start off with a resonance formulation
of the cross-sections and then by energy
averaging you would develop the optical
model and this is a concept which is of
great importance and which we would
refer to over and over again later on he
developed it further with Francis
Friedman and an article in a Bohr
festival book and showed that the energy
averaging had the following effect it
separated the prompt part of the
reaction from the delayed part of the
reaction it did not include the delayed
part of the reaction which would be due
to let's say particles getting caught in
the nucleus and remaining there because
they're in a resonant state for example
so the prompt part was described
the optical potential and that and
that's a phenomenon we want to refer to
over and over again an idea
we've referred to over and over again
this at the same time there were other
prompt processes going on namely the
so-called direct process like deuterons
in protons out in elastic scattering and
so on and for example that was I think
Dave Pease Lee's thesis and so there was
a dilemma which was set up if you wish
or paradox or a problem that's called a
problem in which one we try to develop a
formalism which at the same time
explained the direct reactions the
prompt reactions if you wish explained
the residences and by energy averaging
gave you the optical model now this was
a problem which I didn't attack
frontally what happened was that vicki
one day said to me you know there ought
to be a relation like the cronic
Kramer's relation in optics remember
that's a relation between the real and
imaginary part of the index of
refraction there ought to be such a
relation for nuclear physics or the
passage of say of a neutron through
nuclear matter and that in fact led to a
theory or formalism which did all the
things I just asked for and more I must
tell you that I got the idea for how to
handle that situation sitting in an
airplane behind Vigna so you see
we I had great influences working on me
not only were we able to explain the
three things I just mentioned namely the
direct reaction is the optical model and
the performance of the appropriate
energy averaging which by the way
Michelle Baron J made a very helpful
remark but we also were able to include
the poly principle the poly principle is
of course has to be there when you have
an incident particle which is a nucleon
or composed of nucleons incidence on a
nucleus later we developed this these
particular papers were for protons and
neutrons instant-on nuclei later we
developed the extended the formulism if
you wish for particle transfer reactions
in which let's say yet a proton coming
in or dude around coming out or heavy
iron coming in another heavy iron coming
out so those all can be handled and the
pelicans included but to return to the
main thing that prompt and delayed now
what are the orders of magnitude of
these things well if you take a look at
a neutron resonance resonance of a few
volts electron volts the lifetime is of
the order of 10 to the minus 22 seconds
sorry 10 to the minus 15 seconds and the
other hand the structure that you saw in
in that see in this thing is of the
order of a few MeV or more and that
gives you a lifetime of the time
constant if you wish of the order of 10
to the minus 22 10 and minus 23 seconds
so you have an enormous range between 10
to the minus 15 and 10 to the minus 23
and the question is isn't there
something in between so of course again
instead of asking the question directly
I'll try to answer it directly we
looked at some phenomena you know
without experimentalists we be all dead
and the phenomenon we looked at I looked
at with Barry Bloch was the for not was
shown here it's this is the so-called
strength function which is an average of
the of the width of the let's say of
resonances divided by the energy
disparate distance between them average
as a function of atomic weight and this
solid line was the cloudy crystal ball
model prediction now don't worry about
this stuff here that got understood in
the terms of the fact that these nuclei
were deformed what interest is
interested us was these very low values
here which were you know very far away
from the prediction and the addictions
were very good in here but again there
was a bunch here where one might be
concerned but we really worried about
this arena there and the explanation
turned out to be that if you send a
neutron in let's say it's a nucleus
it'll hail a nucleon a nucleus it'll get
it it'll get the excited and nuclear on
a nucleus will get excited and on that
basis it created two particle one whole
state two particles excited one whole
with one of the particles was now we
thought of this as a doorway state in
the sense that in order to get to the
very complicated compound nuclear wave
functions one had to pass through that
state in order to develop the complexity
and so that was so this this phenomenon
here Jennison li lost this phenomenon
here of these low values was an
indication at the density of
of two-particle one whole states was low
and berry block actually calculated that
on a model and these of points which are
empty are his theoretical values and
here are the experimental values of
filled points so that was the
introduction of doorway States or in
French ekkada pause and the thing that
naturally came up now was well this was
an average so it's an average over
perhaps many doorways states are their
doorway states which are isolated that
stand out by themselves
and actually there were at the time
three different varieties there was the
giant electric dipole resonance there
was the ice of our analog resonance
there was the isomeric efficient
structure and so that came a question
how do you develop carry this theory
further so that one can describe not
only the averages but also the isolated
dovish they residents of which I gave
you some examples and this was worked
out in a paper with Kerman and des
clamor and I didn't elaborate a little
too much on it except for the following
I'd like to show you this very nice
curve
if you look at this up here is
molybdenum PP notice the scale this is
five point two to five point four it's a
high resolution experiment and you get
these characteristic fluctuations which
occur in nuclear reactions if which you
can see if you make a good resolution
experiment if you wish is a sort of a
noise spectrum now if you take a poor
resolution experiment do don't do as
good a job in other words do an average
over this whole thing look what comes
out that's the bottom curve beautiful
beautiful scattering residents proving
that our fundamental ideas on this
matter were correct
now the next step I'll leave this up to
you the next step on might you might
think is obvious namely again let us see
if we can't get structure which is now
in between the doorway state structure
the giant resonance structure and the
compound nucleus structure well again
that's not the way it happened I went to
a meeting in clinique say lakes run by
niccolò syndrome that's a very beautiful
part of what is now Croatia and I hope
it's still there
area with you know it doesn't like
several waterfalls of varying heights
and so forth it's a great place and I my
job was to summarize this conference
which was on among other things which
was known as pre equilibrium reactions I
won't try to define that here now and my
summary said essentially hey this is
great stuff but it ain't quantum
mechanics
and thereby presented myself with a
challenge to to produce the quantum
mechanics well that year that spring
that was in the summer it's the next
spring I had a given invited talk
somewhere and I had him had to invent
the theory which I did which is now
called a statistical multi-step compound
reactions and when I got back to
Cambridge I found out that Steve Koonin
and Arthur Kerman had invented the same
theory so of course we got together and
developed results you have to show that
there was a reason for doing this
beside that my adventure in levite say
let me present such a reason do you see
what was going on where are we to keep
losing this thing what we have here is a
51 vanadium PN reactions of chromium the
energy of the proton is 22 MeV the angle
is 144 degrees it's an experiment done
at Livermore by Grimes and Anderson and
others and these duck these boxes here
the dark points our experiment and this
is the prediction of the Vice Cup Ewing
theory these boxes here so you see by
the time the the this is the excitation
energy of the residual nucleus so this
is low energy neutrons high-energy
neutrons so as we got to high energy
neutrons the statistical Theory failed
miserably to give the experimental
results by orders of magnitude
so that's of course stimulant to look at
it and it was explained by Grimes at
Elle as a again and the as a result of
the presence of doorway states and the
reactions which doli states were
involved in other words it
there were many doorway states and you
averaged over them and that way you got
the got the result which I'll come back
to well that looked very good and in
fact I presented it for Steve and author
of myself at the Munich conference on
international conference in nuclear
physics and we got a very heated letter
from Laura calling the lots of very
great Italian nuclear physicists she
said you can't be right well why can't
we be right well you predict that the
cross-sections anger distributions are
symmetric around 90 degrees and I can
show you reaction after reaction where
they're peaked in the forward direction
well that summer I met with author
Hermann at Los Alamos and we discussed
Laura's problems and we came off with a
solution and I worked the rest of it out
on the plane going home and that became
a statistical multi-step direct reaction
and let me spend a few minutes telling
you about that because it's the answer
to all reaction problems if you wish you
take a typical sorry take a typical
spectrum
let's say a p-n reaction if you wish
this is the energy of the neutron this
is the double differential cross-section
this is the spectrum in this general
arena area low energy neutrons you find
Vicky's evaporation sparkling the
distribution very rapid energy
dependence lots of lots and lots of
fluctuations came known as the arocs of
situations on this end where the
high-energy neutrons in other words not
much energy loss to the nucleus you have
the direct reactions which have a pick
up particular levels and those are very
slow energy dependence as I pointed out
and they're very strongly forward peaked
so we have the whole business to explain
between here and here now well it's
pretty obvious from the beginning is
that interaction time is short here and
long there so you know this whole energy
access Maps roughly onto interaction
time but how do you make the interaction
time long you make it long by developing
complicated States that takes time to do
so not only does energy map into
interaction time it maps as well into
complexity
and let me give a diagrammatic picture
of that how do we get the complexity
well we start out in an initial state
and we develop I'll just look one of
these a daisy-chain in which these
states are more and more complicated and
I'll give you an example of that so that
you know what I'm talking about
suppose for example we have an incident
nucleon it interacts and falls into the
well that the other nucleons exciting
this one of course here you see you have
the two particle one whole state so this
is the doorway state and then you go on
with further interactions and you'll get
three particles this is wrong three
particle two whole States and that
lovely and so on so you get more and
more complexity more and more the
wavefunction of course consists of this
plus that does that amplitudes from each
of these so as you get on to further and
further excitations you'll get more and
more complex now the other case the P
space you start out again up here and
you excite one of these nucleons up this
drops down but doesn't get captured so
this if you wish is a free particle plus
a one particle one whole state and
that's an example of the complexity
now the theory here is developed on a
very basis of two approximations one is
the so called chaining hypothesis which
I'll illustrate back here the chaining
hypothesis is essentially a way for
saying that this process is my coffee
and namely that you don't the
interaction doesn't take you from this
state of complexity to that state of
complexity you have to go through all
the intermediate stages in other words
you can form the interaction on a wave
function in this particular box will
take you either this way this way or
it'll stay there but it won't skip any
of the boxes so that's one apophysis the
other hypothesis is the random phase
which I'll bring up here because it's
[Music]
the random phase says that the various
amplitudes we're going to consider when
averaged will simply be a sum as
indicated of the diagonal values
there'll be no you knew you lambda stuff
now this is important because I haven't
said what new is if new new of course
are the quantum numbers and in the case
of queue space remember where everything
is bound then quantum numbers are simply
J and pi that is the angular momentum
and the parity and if you make the
average and there's no interference
between various values of J or parity
you get of course an angular
distribution which is symmetric about 90
and that's what Kohli Milazzo
complained about it is symmetric about
90 if you're dealing with statistical
northeast
compound reactions on the other hand for
the piece space where at least one
particle is in the continuum you see
that not only do you have the J and the
pi of the residual nucleus but you also
have another quantum number namely this
angular this linear momentum and so the
whole averaging issue changes and you
therefore get a difference between the
multi-step compound and the multi-step
direct well I'm obviously not going to
work all of this out for you in detail
but let me just show you some of the
results you remember we showed you this
curve here and now if you include some
of these multi-step compounds and add
that on to this curve you get these X's
that's done with one parameter I'll come
back to the parameters later and Steve
Koonin worked this out as well as the
next one which illustrates the method
this I believe is tantalum it's at a
large angle so that it's multi-step
compound and here is the experimental
curve and here is what you get just from
evaporation again you see this huge
difference this is what you get but you
add in the multi-step compound the sum
is here at this then you've got to add
in two neutrons and three neutrons what
you simply do from evaporation theory
you get the final answer there
now in the multi-step direct domain a
lot of many many reactions have been
studied by Colima lot so linetti and
[Music]
Peter Peter Peter what's your name I'll
remember it later and they have to hand
it to Laura colleague and vanetti
because they got ahold of a preprint of
ours which had an infinite number of
mistakes in it typos of various kinds
and they were able to decipher it and
actually go to work and this is their
results
Hudson Peter Hudson so we have here
again as you that's the excitation
energy this is the neutron energy
spectrum this is 30 degrees energy is 45
MeV and you can see this is the result
if we have only one step so this is a
wish you wish the direct usual direct
calculation and as you see it will fail
at low energies you weigh it in two
steps three steps these don't not so far
down they don't matter and your final
result is this curve and it not just
pretty well with the data not in this
region because they didn't that in the
two and three Neutron evaporation things
so bear in mind that in this case one
single collision did very well at least
for the high-energy neutrons now if you
go to 90 degrees here's again the result
and you can see that a single single
step just fails very quickly you've got
to add in two and three steps before you
can get this curve here and now if you
go to four steps
I'm sorry if you put a another angle so
now 120 degrees and now you see one step
really is only a value at the very
highest energy two steps and three steps
are needed in order to get this curve
these are semi log plot so these
deviations are substantial but the
general tenor and and behavior of the
cross sections are well represented let
me do one more of these
this is now the angular distribution up
to the time that this theory was
developed really people depended upon
the direct reaction
theory and so they didn't do anything
about the big angles but as you can see
this is the excitation energy the
nucleus and you can see for both high
and low energy it does quite well that's
rather old actually but there have been
a great many experiments done since then
with that kind of treatment and I'll
give you the last one I saw now at one
hundred and fifty MeV remember the other
data was that forty five and we've also
done it at lower energies well the one
with Grimes at always at twenty so here
we have nickel 150 MeV and these are the
various energies of the emergent protons
and I'll just point out that here are
the experimental points and the that is
here not so hotsy-totsy here but after
all if the theory is any worth anything
it has to be wrong sometimes it's if it
can't be wrong it can't be right now
here is the single scattering at one
step two steps three steps four steps
five steps and of course as you can see
it as you increase the number of steps
you have you know the the gut feeling
that this is doing the right thing
because the hut in order to get two big
angles you should need more steps and
there's another one of these curves
the authors are down here their group
from South Africa he is Hudson and
Benetti who did of course the work on
analyzing now this is different
100 120 150 and you can see the nature
of the fits at each of these energies
now if you're interested in
phenomenology that sort of thing you say
well how many how many how many
parameters that you use to fit that data
the answer is that a given energy only
one parameter and independent of the
nucleus and independent of whether it
was a a statistical multi-step compound
there was the test of a multi-step
direct and here are the parameters this
is the coupling potential B naught right
here which gives you the probability if
you wish to magnitude the probability of
going from one complex at E to the next
complexity and it flows along a curve
like this it's a totally reasonable
curve it's the same curve essentially
parallel to the behavior of the central
part of the optical tential as a
function of energy so I'll finish up was
just two other examples as you remember
Vicki said is there a krama scoring
relation for nuclear reactor
interactions the answer is yes and in
that early paper 58 1958 that
relationship was developed recently
Claude Maho has looked at this in some
detail and I want to show you this
result remember you relate the real to
the imaginary part the imaginary part
the optical sense you essentially you
get out of looking at reaction rates and
so usually you have pretty good
information about that
and then you stick that into the
relationship and predict the real pause
so he tested it out and here is alpha by
the way not just for this case but never
mind now this is not quite the potential
it's the integral of the potential over
space V represents the real part W of
the imaginary part and as you expect the
imaginary part has a a threshold and
then it's fairly constant actually
eventually grows logarithmically but
over this domain this is a
representation so he approximated this
by a functional straight line plus the
constants then you can do the dispersion
integrals and this is the prediction for
the solid line the solid line for the
broken line the broken line and these
points here are experimental points so
you see yes there is a promise
chronic relation professor of
ice-covered for this kind of store for a
nuclear matter now I didn't tell you
what the answers were like for the
multi-step compound multi-step direct
they're really quite looked good when
you see them at the end they feel right
and for the multi-step direct what it
consisted of is a series of foldings you
take a scattering the first step and you
so you make you get to the first stage
of complexity let's say them with them
started out with an initial momentum K
sub R you go to case of one then you
take another step that means you go from
states with case of one two states with
case of two you do that by folding then
you go from K to the K 3 and so forth
until you come to n steps and at the end
you want to have the final momentum so
that means you've achieved though
so the final momentum in n steps and now
you sum over n now there is a phenomenon
and heavy ions called deep inelastic
scattering in which the two heavy ions
have a nice conversation with each other
but they don't get into bed with each
other they don't be formed compound
nuclei they exchange particles verbs
nouns adjectives and so on but they and
hang around for quite a long time but
they don't as I say form a compound
nucleus now this is just set up for
multi-step direct reactions and we
looked at that with bent Lauritzen and
in the limit in which the change in
momentum and the change in angular
momenta are between steps is small that
is going from step one to three and for
each step involves a small change if you
do that then you derive from our general
expressions a clunk equation in
momentum and angle Menem space and then
by ingenious strategies you can
integrate that equation that's a law by
the way it's approximation that's used
it has the advantage that it is quick
and dirty and gives you an answer and
you can do it in a relatively short time
and this is the kind of result you get
this reproduction didn't come out too
well it's a this cross section you again
as the excitation energy theta is the
angle so it's D theta notice not sine
theta beta it's 40 argon-40 and
thorium-232 and the energy is 388 MeV
and
these this is the experimental situation
these are three fits and this is the one
we like the best you can see this part
of the structure is well-developed this
part of the structure is also well
developed the thing we miss is this
piece and here is of course that's
experimental era but as you can see the
theory does a nice job in at least
qualitatively looking at this I think
I'm going to stop here I could go on
indefinite period I haven't mentioned a
lot of reaction work that was done at
MIT there is the infamous of famous
Kerman McManus and faileth description
of multiple scattering which is the
basis of the understanding of let's say
1 GeV protons on nuclei
there's the time-dependent hartree-fock
which maybe Steve will talk about there
is the boundary condition model that
that our Lohmann is used in discussing
pioneer Kleon scattering and there's a
doorway state formalism that Moniz lends
Moniz and yasaka used in discussing
nucleus scattering they had a rather
ingenious generalization which I wish I
had time to discuss with you
most of this work was done while I was
administrating like mad which I did for
about 20 odd years and the only reason
it got done is because I had superb
students did all the work and I had the
collaboration with my friends
Niki vise cup and alpha Kerman and I
want to take this opportunity to thank
them publicly
acknowledge my debt to them publicly and
I also want to thank laboratory for
nuclear science which made it possible
to work that hard thank you
[Applause]